the first movie was such a huge head and
it influenced millions of people
worldwide as mothers and as
professionals when you're going around
to do the circuit again this whole thing
frozen tears gonna be massive how do you
balance that like letting your kids know
that you're I'm busy working but also
maybe including them in the fun of what
this all is like what is the balance
there we share a lot tips and tidbits
that is part of the balance is talking
to other moms I think I've recently
always used to think balance is a
four-letter word like it's just there's
no way to get it and recently I've kind
of isolated how I feel about it
I think in order to get balance you just
need to get uncomfort you need to get
comfortable with uncomfortable feelings
when you are at work you will miss your
children when you were at home you will
think about work opportunities it will
never go away
and the sooner that you get comfortable
we'll never be happy that you are never
the better but there is like there's
like sort of a release in that like
there's once you just move into
acceptance mode and then you also make
the best educated decisions for your
kids like I don't bring my kids to the
premiere because they don't do well in
situations where I'm with them and I
can't pay attention to them yeah it's
why the only thing that makes me bristle
is sometimes when we're in public and
people will come up to me and want to
talk I'm desperate to tell them I I'm so
happy that you're a fan I need to be a
mom right now because this little person
is my priority so as much as I want to
share or take a picture I have to focus
here because I'm a mom so when I go to
the premiere I can't I can't do my job
because they are wanting to be with me
so I just think it's better for them to
stay home and thankfully Disney is kind
enough to give us a screening I've a
slate between whining him I think it's
important that he sees a woman working
doing a job she loves to do I think that
that's the kind of you know I want to be
that kind of role model for my son that
I not only do our work but I
I care that I love my work and then I'm
passionate about my work and that my
work makes me feel good because
sometimes you know I'm constantly
feeling guilty I'm leaving should I be
there today he's not feeling that well
I'm here with you guys I've all the
guilt but he also needs to understand
that that it's important to do what you
love in life you know and so I'm
constantly going back and forth as to
what the right thing is to do and when I
should be prioritizing him and when I
it's a good lesson for him to see
somebody working towards their dreams
you know they also did a study I think
that that came out a couple years ago
saying that it's hard for children to
see especially mom who's generally the
primary caregiver work but the outcome
of that when they're an adult is that
they have this unbelievable education
about not just a female but a parent who
loves and it was dedicated to hard work
so it might be difficult for them but
it's actually good for kids to skrutz to
struggle sometimes it develops great
character so I had read that a couple
years ago and I thought oh it's okay
that I'm keeping my career and having
kids because that's actually gonna be
really good for them to see that mommy
was a hard-working woman well a good
role model yeah good role model for your
kids right now the thing that's
confusing which we were talking about
before you you sat down was was if our
kids don't care about frozen very much
because they they don't we don't float
you know flash it in their faces all the
time and mom singing and doing our lines
it's like annoying
all right kids what is it it mean that
I'm projecting that I would like my son
to think I'm cool what what is that it's
a this is very important to me this puts
a roof over your head or should you just
be quiet and you doesn't matter yeah so
funny well you know all the times movies
are sort of guideposts like moral
guideposts for people certain so that I
have kids and so I go you know I'll look
at these characters and how they're
handling this situation they might never
be in a situation like on an Elsa are
because they don't have magic powers but
you know this is kind of how to do it
when you when you think about on a NASA
as sisters and like you say you you see
your kids maybe
wobbling or fighting to just go look at
these to do it I said I absolutely do
first of all it's easier we're monkeys
right we learned from watching each
other that's like that that's a strong
characteristics or monkeys we watch our
alphas we see however we're mimics yeah
you know we ape each other and I when
they do fight which is totally normal
I say how do you think on and Elsa would
handle this how would Anna and Elsa
treat each other just to get them out of
their perspective of like I want to
wring my sister's neck and think oh I'm
remembering this story about familial
love and siblings who put each other's
priorities first it's an easier way to
sort of get out of your frustrated zone
and I say it's my kids quite often yeah
now I've just recently got let it go out
of my head like it's been stuck in my
head since 2013 yeah yeah when you look
at the new movie is there a song that
immediately you go this is the one this
is the stand-out no one's gonna be able
to get inside of the head I'll take that
it's called into the unknown in my head
for about two years
it's it I think it is the let it go of
this movie it's the one where yet again
just Edina sort of soars and it's so
almost annoyingly catchy my head I am I
actually really like I have to to pretty
epic songs and we don't talk about the
second one because it's kind of in a
spoiler so hopefully we'll see how
because I think it's a really self
empowering song for kids to the message
so I'm curious to see how it will kind
of like but we'll have once the movie is
seen and we don't have to worry about
what the what it says I'm actually
curious because because Edina has to
because our filmmakers are smart and
they were like great well we had one let
it go so we just you know like what I'm
excited to see the other ones been
announced write the name the name of it
I south people show ya show yourself so
between show yourself and into the
unknown and then she's got this
beautiful beautiful ballad then you're
gonna be blown away by it breaks your
heart so it's some the music is really
good
really good yeah you guys have each
other's backs like if I talk about the
songs and immediately like her songs are
amazing obviously you know she's got an
amazing song like you guys really have
this this sister thing is is it a bond
that started when you obviously did the
first movie yeah we loved each other
it started from you when we met yeah
because I my first meeting with Adina
was F before a table read for frozen
they were like can you go to Idina
Menzel's house and practice come up with
a duet that could be for sisters to say
who's there was no music written yet for
this script and then she came out
Foreman in a board room and I was like
wind beneath my wings driving - Adina
came up our be cool just be cool and she
was so lovely she was like we do this
it's okay standing at a piano like
shaking singing with her it's nice to me
and then we did that together you know
and got the roles and been on this
journey so yeah that's awesome well I'm
exhausted pledge but I can't wait to see
the whole thing and obviously my kids
are gonna be over the moon for it so how
old are your kids they're insects yeah
it's like perfect yeah guys thank you so
much thank you so much